great we have our breath now we're ready
to solve this guy tan theta equals 1 so
I'm going to take my other color if
you've got another color will be
enormously and then I'm going to put a
line through at it's gonna be about you
so now that I've put my line through I
can see again sign to get the patent I
have two points of intersection right I
have this first one over here and then I
have another one a little bit further
along okay what tools should i use to
find that first solution we used sine
inverse of the sine we use cos inverse
because let's use tan inverse pétain ok
so I'm going to go theta equals and in
my calculator i'm going to go to tan
inverse of 1 okay but you may recognize
again this is an exact value the angry
you should get is 45 degrees ok now just
was again you always do this does it
look about right on your graph you're
expecting something between not a 90 see
that yeah 45 it looks about right ok so
great I have my first answer but that's
only one of them how do i get to this
next one mmm this one's a bit trickier
180 plus 20 ok now we use symmetry to
get from 60 to 300 right we're going to
different kind of symmetry here remember
TEDx is periodic it copies itself every
180 degrees right so when I have 45
degrees here to get over to the next
solution right can you see from here to
here it's 180 so from here to here will
also be a hundred and eighty right so
I'm going to go further is retreat
that's why we're doing is it's ok
alright so therefore if my first answer
was 45 coincidentally for this one it
ends up being 180 plus 45 which is 225
and sure enough if you go to calculate
up you copy in 10 to 25 if you calculate
this anything right that's all ill think
about
yes now interestingly enough i did
mention this and it is a coincidence and
i'll show you why in a second okay it
does seem like this equals 270 takeaway
for you to manage raise ? okay now i'm
going to say to you that's a coincidence
and here is why okay let's just quickly
try another one let's try for instance
so you put your sundays we don't need to
draw a new ground let's just try tan
theta equals root 3 let's just try this
guy okay now one we know what that is
root 3 is about 1.7 you can chuck any
calculator and check out of line so
therefore if what is here root 3 is
going to be higher right it's going to
be something like this there's root 3
okay you're right with that so i'm going
to go through exactly the same process
now if i go up to here just like for
this angle i can do 10 of us and that
should give me the first solution right
why don't you check it out what are you
going to get when you do 10 inverse of
root 3 what does it hedges should hide
your 60 in fact you want to go to guess
that can you see look 45 and it's going
to go a little further along it's got to
be bigger than 45 got to be less than 90
60 s kind of one of those big candidates
right so my first solution is it great
now when I look for my next solution hmm
if you guessed that maybe I could try
out to 70 take away 60 to 70 take away
60 would be 210 degrees right I can test
this out I don't need to guess right so
if i go to my calculator if i put in 10
or 60 which is my first solution it
gives me that 1.7 answer that's ripped
through let's just try to 10 just give
it a shot and you get something entirely
different you still get a am i sir just
a completely different one it's not it's
not 1.7 at all okay and the reason why
is because
running on colors for you here is my 60
degrees that's how far I've gone to the
first able okay if I wanted to do 270
take away bad right I'm actually going
to go too far I'm going to blow past my
solution do you see that like if I were
at 60 degrees this way and 60 degrees
this way another way of saying it is if
you have a look at this shape it's not
symmetrical the way this one is now you
see how this one is reflection airy
similar so you go in one way go at the
other okay but here you don't have that
kind of shape in fact i'm not going
forwards and backwards i'm just going
forwards and more forward so instead our
solution for this guy will not be 270
take away after state it's going to be
180 plus my first angle which would be
soo 40 okay which you can try and you
calculate a 10 to 40 sure enough will
give you three okay